-Our first guest
is a country-music superstar
whose new album
"Body Language (Deluxe),"
is out tomorrow.
He's also a great coach
on "The Voice,"
which airs Mondays and Tuesdays
at 8:00 p.m., on NBC.
Please welcome,
the one and only, Blake Shelton.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow.
Blake.
Thank you for being here,
and thank you
for playing a game.
Because I just -- we saw each
other recently, in person.
-Yeah.
-You helped me out on my show,
"That's My Jam,"
and we played some games.
And I just know --
You had fun, right?
-Oh, yeah,
and now you're helping me out
by having me
play more of your games...
[ Laughter ]
...on the show.
Thanks for the opportunities.
[ Laughter ]
I appreciate it.
-I will say, you were
a good sport on the show,
and I appreciate you doing it.
Although, I think
you do have to brush up
on your Taylor Swift songs.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, because you --
[ Laughter ]
You didn't really know that.
But I'm assuming
you must have run into
each other in Nashville,
or something.
-Look, listen to me,
there's Taylor Swift --
there's the country
Taylor Swift,
which I know some of that.
-Yeah.
-I'm not as familiar
with the new Taylor Swift 2.0,
which is, you know,
the pop version, you know?
I'm still --
I'm still stuck when she was
doing her country records.
-Yeah.
You think you --
-You don't do any country music
on "That's My Jam," by the way.
Because you had Ariana there,
and so you were totally
sucking up to Ariana
and trying throw music at her
that you thought
she would guess.
-That's not true.
-And little did you know
that Kelly Clarkson
is such a nerd
that she knows every song
on the planet,
because she sings a different
song on her show every day.
So she knows every word
to every song.
-Yeah, but, also, I know,
by talking to you,
you're like
a musical encyclopedia.
I could name a song, and you
could tell me who sings it.
Like, who sings
"The Piña Colada Song"?
-Rupert Holmes.
-How the heck
could you know that?
-Well, I just happened
to know that one.
That was a lucky guess.
[ Laughter ]
-No, you're fantastic.
So I figured --
So when we were playing
the game, I had you sing
the theme from
"The Golden Girls."
I thought that was --
-I did.
I felt like I did a good job
on that, by the way.
-You crushed it.
-I mean, I don't want to --
I don't want to brag, but...
-Too late.
Too late --
you already bragged.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
I want to talk to you about
the new album.
I want to talk about
"Body Language (Deluxe)."
But first, I want to talk about
your wedding.
Look at this.
Look at the beautiful couple
right here.
Look at that.
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Unbelievable.
-You know...
-Beautiful.
-Gwen and I agreed that
we like to take our
publicity stunts all the way.
[ Laughter ]
So we thought we would go ahead
and just seal the deal.
-That's so funny.
-Know what I'm saying?
-It looked great.
I just thought it was
a beautiful -- everything
I've seen and things --
I mean, I didn't hear from you
or anything,
you know, personally, and say,
"Hey, Jimmy, what are you doing?
Are you busy this week?"
[ Laughter ]
You know what?
Not much planning went into it.
I understand.
Who puts planning
into a wedding, you know?
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, I just remember
not being invited, and I go --
-We only had room
for one NBC host at the wedding,
so we had Carson.
-Yeah, Carson Daly was there.
That's true, yeah.
But I've known you and Gwen
for a long time,
and I just figured, you know...
I didn't figure anything,
really, you know?
I was just sitting at home,
trying to, like, see --
read on Twitter
how's the wedding going.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, it seemed like a blast.
Uh...
[ Laughter continues ]
Did you save me a piece of cake
or anything?
I mean, maybe that, you sent --
Please don't
send me that banana.
-You're always trying to make me
feel like Super Dave Osborne.
Remember Super Dave Osborne?
-No, I do not.
I do not, I do not.
-You do that every time.
We talked about this last time.
-No, I don't.
-And I end up coming across
as the grumpy guy.
Trying to be festive,
wearing a Santa hat,
and then you just kick me
in the nuts over and over
on national television.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How can you be mad at --
How could you be mad
at this little guy?
Look at this little guy.
Aww.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
Look, that's you and Gwen.
-That's back when Gwen and I
used to be brother and sister.
[ Laughter, audience groans ]
Way back in the day.
[ Laughter continues ]
-Oh, my God!
[ Laughter ]
-You know, that was years ago.
-Dude, you're unbelievable.
[ Both laugh ]
But when you --
When you did your own vows
for the wedding...
-Yeah.
-...you surprised Gwen,
and you actually sang your vows.
Is that correct?
-I did.
Well, Carson told me that --
He told both of us
that he expected us to write our
vows for the wedding and --
which is a lot of pressure.
Because, you know,
as easy as it is for Gwen and I
to get up and sing, you know,
to, like, write something down
and say it is really awkward.
And so I just copped out,
went ahead,
and wrote something down
that I could sing.
And so I wrote this song.
I wrote it with a buddy
named Craig Wiseman, actually,
and it's on this album
that comes out.
It comes out tomorrow, I think.
-That's correct.
-When does this air?
Does this air tonight?
Are we live?
-You don't know
when my show airs?
Yeah, it's on eve--
"The Tonight Show."
At this point,
your album is out.
It's past midnight.
-You come on after --
Who do you come on after?
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, I don't know
if it's midnight or --
-It is now midnight.
It's now midnight.
It's past midnight,
and this album is out.
"Body Language (Deluxe)"
is out right now.
This is out.
It's available.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You can get the song.
"We Can Reach the Stars."
-That's the song.
That's the song
I wrote for Gwen Stefani.
-Wow.
-My wife.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love that.
-I hear the mixed reaction there
in the studio audience.
[ Laughter ]
Like, there was a few gasps.
-A little bummed out
because we thought --
Which one did you write for me?
Was it
"Monday Morning Missing You"?
[ Laughter ]
Or was it "Corn"?
-No.
-Was it "Corn"?
-No, but --
-Don't you --
Please don't bring out the --
Oh, my God. Please don't
bring out that banana.
-I'm really inspired by this.
-Get rid of that stupid thing!
Get rid of that dumb thing.
-I'm really inspired by this.
I think we should
write a song about it.
-I want to talk to you about
"The Voice" when we come back.
All right,
more with Blake Shelton,
everybody, when we come back.